this is Sansa for ian's Cemetery just
outside the town of monks in Belgium and
this will be the focus for the
commemorations to remember the centenary
of the outbreak of World War one it has
been chosen not because it's the largest
cemetery of its kind not by some way it
is one of the most beautiful however and
it has quite a poignant story attached
to it on the 23rd of August 1914 the
British Expeditionary Force were camped
in their positions
just outside Mons by one edge of the
canal the morning was misty and damp
they had just arrived in Belgium and
they didn't know the size of the German
force that they faced but by 10 o'clock
in the morning the Summer Sun had burnt
off much of the mist and it became quite
clear that the enemy was far bigger than
they first thought the British fought
valiantly but to all intents and
purposes they were grossly outnumbered
and by evening they were in retreat they
had lost the Battle of Mons the first
victory of the Great War was Germany's
the following year 1915 the Germans dug
up the bodies that had died in this area
both British and German and they wanted
to bury them here on this patch of land
and the man who owned this land said you
can have it I'll give it to you on one
condition and that condition is that you
bury the British with the same respect
as you bury your own and the Germans did
exactly that by 1919 after the end of
the war it went into the hands of what
was then known as the Imperial War
Graves Commission now the Commonwealth
War Graves Commission and they to this
day have looked after it with the same
traditions and the same love and care
and attention as they do all of their
graveyards around the world and in this
cemetery there is roughly the same
number
of Commonwealth graves as there are
German 229 Commonwealth 284 German there
are two particularly significant graves
the first that a private John Parr the
Middlesex regiment killed on the 21st of
August 1914 aged 18 he was shot dead by
a sniper's bullet from a German rifle he
was the first British soldier killed on
the Western Front in the Great War and
then there is the grave of private GE
Ellison George Ellison of the 5th
Lancers killed on the 11th of November
1918 aged 40 hours before the
Declaration of Armistice was signed
George Allison was the last British
soldier to be killed on the Western
Front in life they fought for the same
king and country but they didn't know
each other in death their graves by
sheer coincidence faced one another